[Music]
you have the greatest collection of old
cool motorcycles I do have some
beautiful bikes yeah older I've always
ridden good C's motor good C's the
Italian
yikes yeah which are sort of nation away
it was my first big bike so I've always
had a real soft spot for them and I love
them I have some early seventies gute
C's and all the way up until modern day
ones you've got like cafe racer bikes
things like that yes where I am some
yeah they have I think we have do you
drove a bike here today didn't you bike
here to the lot yep so you're just
constantly around riding these cool bike
it's just how I get around I mean I ride
new bikes if I'm gonna be going on the 4
or 5 or the you know to get up up here
you don't want to be knocking about on
the highways on old old bikes really cuz
they don't work very well they very
sometimes don't stop or sometimes they
don't sometimes they don't go yeah and I
love that they don't stop sometimes but
that's okay as long as you're not on the
405 you think it's fine to be riding
around somewhere else Memphis all right
riding along the coast and the wheel
goes that way and you go this way you
know on the motorway I also picture this
is I think a picture of one of your
bikes that we have here you beautiful
bike with a sidecar is that your dog
that's are you just stealing dogs now
yeah court what yeah it's a gorgeous
bike yeah that's the new but I mean it's
not new which bike may they just never
changed I think in the Second World War
the Russians captured some BMW
motorbikes from the Germans and they
copied them and they still make them to
that day because I don't come to this
day yeah so you ride around would you
ever include someone like me could I fit
in the sidecar would you ever give me a
ride where I'm in the sidecar and you're
driving around that would I fit you
really mean you'd be as tall as me in it
because you're much taller than me back
no I'd look like big bird from Sesame
Street heads has joined the German army
you know it's funny you also like you
like older cars you put a car up for
sale on eBay a couple of weeks ago check
this out and you used your own name you
said you and McGregor is selling this
was that a 19 1960 Volkswagen yeah it
was a 1960 M
Volkswagen Beetle I like old bugs and
the
use and I bought this one in them I just
had one too many and I do I like to keep
I like to buy other ones and I always
sell one if I'm buying a new one so that
I so that I can tell my wife I'm not
spending any money on yeah and then and
I try to not to do that so this one went
and I use my own name because people who
paid more money for them if you do
[Laughter]
that's nice why shouldn't you get a
little extra because they're people that
like no I want to have I want to be able
said this is you and McGregor's 1960 bug
right so therefore yeah there we go
there you go that's fantastic right felt
sold a beetle recently just a start as
far as I understand it's very standard
1960s bug and it went for over a hundred
thousand dollars yeah oh I say he's a
far more popular in the BPW world than I
am I have I've sold five cars as Jerry
Seinfeld really well and very well then
I find that it's me and they're mad
Jerry can't be here sorry it's just me
yeah
Jerry sent me to handle his contracts
yeah
you